speaking of Apollo 11 fifty years ago
tomorrow it blasted off from Earth on
its historic mission to the moon all
this week we're celebrating that
accomplishment and where we've come
since in a series of stories and
interviews today we look at some of the
legendary figures of the Apollo mission
Charlie Duke was the voice on the radio
talking to the astronauts as flight
director Gene Kranz led Mission Control
during the lunar landing and above the
moon Michael Collins piloted the Apollo
11 command module while his fellow
astronauts walked on the moon's surface
Mark Strassman spoke with all three he's
at Kennedy Space Center Visitor Complex
in Florida mark does it look the same as
you imagine it did 50 years ago well
that's what I want to talk about here
Anthony I mean I'm standing underneath a
Saturn 5 rocket this is the type that
launched Apollo 11 screw to the moon and
I mean seriously would you take a look
at how big it is 363 feet long that's
taller than the Statue of Liberty and
the most powerful machine ever built and
riding on top was a lunar lander just
like this one that brought the first men
to the moon
[Music]
when the Saturn 5 rocket roars life the
Apollo 11 mission soared into history
everything going well for a landing on
the moon
NASA's doers and dreamers sent three
moon explorers astronauts Neil Armstrong
Buzz Aldrin and Michael Collins the
three of us were just a tip of a
gigantic technological iceberg if you
will Collins now 88 told us at liftoff
Apollo 11s crew felt g-force pressure
and more we felt the weight of the world
on our shoulders everyone was looking we
were worried that we're gonna screw
something up no wonder the whole world
was watching American pride was also on
the line the president is now looking
inside the mercury capsule to achieve a
goal set by President Kennedy eight
years earlier before this decade is out
of landing a man on the moon and
returning him safely to the earth
after a three-day trip the moon landing
broadcast live drama 240,000 miles back
to earth Capcom work gofer undocking
Collins stayed behind in the command
module as Armstrong and Aldrin descended
to the moon's surface but their lunar
landers autopilot was sending them
toward a crater and it was a very large
crater but as Armstrong told Edie
Bradley in 60 minutes
in 2005 steep slopes on the crater
covered with very large rocks both sides
of automobiles that was not the kind of
place I wanted to try to make the first
landing Armstrong flying manually had to
improvise
he had roughly one minute of fuel to
find a safe place to land
legendary flight director Gene Kranz was
in charge at Houston's Mission Control
because it's like driving your car with
gas gauge reading empty the tension was
through the roof Charlie Duke also in
Mission Control was the man telling
Armstrong he was flying on fumes tension
you could see tension you could feel
feel more dead silent I'd never heard
Mission Control so quiet so that tension
it was palpable you could feel it
Armstrong finally spotted
moves terrain and we finally landed one
thing right nobody knows exactly how
much fuel some estimates evident 20
seconds and we copy it down eagle
[Applause]
Charlie Duke was now speaking to the
first men on the moon quality we copy on
the ground you got a bunch of guys about
to turn blue we're breathing again
thanks a lot the significance of what he
had just done the piloting this thing
into this landing over these significant
problems that they had on the decent was
remarkable so remarkable
almost everyone alive today has seen
these grainy images Earth's first two
moon Walker's six hundred million people
back on earth watched them transfixed it
really to me brought the u.s. together
and was very significant especially
given the turmoil yeah of that decade
right it's still hard for me to believe
that we've been there we did that we
accomplished that Armstrong and Aldrin
spent almost a day on the surface the
dust they kicked up left them covered in
lunar mystique Armstrong died in 2012
but his name never will
it's a brilliant surface and in that
sunlight predominantly gray it's an
interesting place to be I recommend it
what's old is new again for NASA the new
mission is to put more men and the first
women on the moon the goal is 2024 but
the program is years behind schedule has
had billions in overruns and Tony all of
that proves once again how difficult and
how significant that first moon landing
really was yeah that's right mark you
know I'm rootin for Walter Cronkite was
rooted back and they seemed getting
nervous watching it all over again I
remember him being nervous fifty years
ago but just watching it again
so President Nixon speechwriters
actually prepared a speech in case they
were unable to get back from the moon
those who went to explore the moon in
peace will rest there in peace was the
line that was never used it was dicey
they never had to use it Walter Cronkite
one of the most unflappable men in the
history of broadcast just takes the
glasses off and says Wow nice commentary
I'll take that hour on CM tomorrow I
will be at Kennedy Space Center to cover
the Apollo 11 anniversary will also
bring you an interview with astronauts
onboard the International Space Station
and CBS News will air a special report
to mark the moment Apollo 11 blasted off
50 years ago that's tomorrow
around 9:30 Eastern 9:30 to was when the
liftoff was 8:30 Central right here on
CBS